- [Tzoori Tamam] Hi, welcome.
Welcome to Reinvent 2025.
I, I hope you've enjoyed your first day,
and hopefully you'll enjoy
the rest of the week.
My name is Tzoori Tamam,
I'm a solutions architect specialist
for ED Services at AWS.
It's a mouthful, I know.
And with me is Dan Avidan from HSBC.
He'll introduced us himself a bit later
into the, into the presentation.
Today, we're gonna cover
at a level 300 talk,
a typical, or maybe not so typical day,
in a WAF administrator life.
It will be a bit hectic.
It will be a bit technical.
The fact that it's a level 300 talk
means that we assume that you know
some things about AWS WAF already.
So we won't dive into the, what are rules
or what are actions?
We, we'll dive a bit into labels
and maybe a bit more of the new stuff,
but we assume some level,
some technical level from the get-go.
Apologies for the pace.
I, I, I talk fast naturally,
and we have a lot to pack into 60 minutes,
so I'll be even faster.
You can watch it later on YouTube
at like, 75, point 75 and
it will make more sense,
but for now, it's gonna be rushed.
We'll have this talk
built in a way of a story.
I'll, I'll, I'll make belief as if
I'm a WAF administrator and I'll take,
take you through one of my days.
But later we'll have an
actual story by Dan at HSBC,
who will discuss the way they journey
through adopting AWS WAF.
So with that, we'll start at waking up.
It's morning, a new day,
a new web application.
So I just got a, a, a notification
in the morning, on the way to work,
that there's a new application out there.
My company probably
misunderstood the hype with bots
and AI bots, and they built an actual bot,
robot-selling website and mobile app.
So there's this new application that
now I, as the WAF administrator,
need to go out and protect.
Initially, this is the architecture.
So it's built to serve
web users, mobile applications,
sending typically API calls
as well as, well, unknown
automated clients,
such as good bots and bad bots.
So it's just out there
and everybody can use it.
It will initially hit CloudFront,
our CDN service,
as the ingress point.
And from there, CloudFront will route
the traffic into multiple
backend components,
or really front-end components,
at the back of CloudFront.
We'll have an ALB act as the
load balancer for the web components,
we'll have an API gateway
that will route API calls
to different Lambda workers
and Lambda integrations,
and we'll have static content.
It's a single page application eventually.
So the HTMLs and the CSS files
and JavaScript files all
hosted on an S3 bucket.
And, and CloudFront will
take care of all that.
Now, this is my headache.
Like, I got my morning coffee
and now I need to decide how I do it.
How do I protect this
newly birthed application?
So, there are multiple questions
we need to ask ourselves when we decide
how to protect a specific application.
We need to ask ourself where?
So where do we protect it?
We install multiple components.
Where do we put WAF?
Do we put it at the very
edge, on CloudFront?
Do we have separate
WAFs on the API gateway
and on the ALB?
Where should we put it?
And it really depends.
It depends on who's gonna manage it
and how much time do they have?
If we want to spend time and really tune
each and every policy for the different
components of the application,
probably it will make sense to
have different web application
firewall policies on top of the
ALB and the API gateway.
But we don't have that much time to manage
all of these applications separately.
And more, most importantly,
we would want to block attacks
as they come in at the
very edge of the network.
So, we will look into the different
places we can put WAF.
Probably will enable it on CloudFront.
Then, when?
When do we need this
application protected?
If we have time, we can plan ahead
and start things in staging
and test it out and tune it.
And then when we're, we're,
when we're ready to
launch into production,
we can start turning
on the different rules.
But I got this call this morning
and the when is now.
So the application is already out there,
I have to protect it.
So in this case, typically,
we have to make some compromises.
We never have all the time in the world.
So typically there is some, some
urgency when we deploy WAF.
So we will need to make some compromises,
at least initially.
We will need to decide that
some things will go on
immediately in blocking modes.
Other things will go on in count mode
so we can tune them as traffic starts
to flow through the application.
But again, this remains to be seen.
We need to turn it on
and see what happens.
Another question is who?
So, who's gonna manage this
web application firewall policy?
Is it me, the security guy?
Is it the application people?
Each application component
has its own WAF policy,
and that means that each of these people
need to manage their own WAF.
This really changes the complexity
that I can basically put on them.
So if they need to manage something
they don't know really well,
they will typically do simple things.
On the other hand, if
the application people
are managing the web
application firewall policy,
they really know when to introduce
new changes to the application
and they really know
what those changes are.
So they can tune the web
application firewall policy
according to those application changes.
So again, we need to balance things out.
We need to understand and
decide what goes where
and who manages what.
And finally, the what.
So, a WAF policy is a complex thing.
It can do many different things.
Obviously, we can go and turn on
all of the different toggles.
Probably it will be a mess.
Probably some things will get blocked
that weren't meant to be blocked,
and we'll have to roll
back and do something else.
So the what is,
what are we putting in place, day one?
And what are we planning
to put in place day 100?
And how do we plan to roll that out?
So, what will my policy contain?
So we don't have time
for everything today,
so we focus on these two questions:
On the where and on the
what, for this talk.
As for the where, one thing we can do,
and that's typically the best option,
is to put a WAF policy
on top of CloudFront.
Why? Well, initially we
want to block traffic
at the very edge, especially if
we're talking about volumetric attacks.
We do not want them to reach all the way
into our origins, into our VPC.
There are multiple reasons for
why we don't want to do that.
But remember that with CloudFront,
we have 750 plus points of presence,
all of them are hun-,
hundreds of gigabytes,
gigabit per second capacity.
So it's a very well-built mechanism,
built and designed to withstand
these peaks in traffic.
So, blocking bad traffic at that point
makes a lot of sense, right?
On the other hand, we
might also want to consider
building web application
firewall policies,
smaller ones, more granular ones,
and put them in place on top of
the different application components
and maybe let the application
people handle them.
So some designs, we see that
we have a coarse grain control
at the very front, on top of CloudFront,
with finer grain controls,
with smaller WAF policies,
running on top of the underlying services.
ALB, API, Gateway, App Runner, whatever.
At the very least, we do wanna see
WAF running on CloudFront.
That would be the best place
to start blocking incoming attacks.
Once we have put CloudFront
on top of the application,
there is one consideration
we have to think of,
and that is, how do we make sure
that no one bypasses our WAF?
And for that, we, we have to utilize
mechanisms known as origin
cloaking or origin masquerading.
Basically, we want to make
sure that only traffic
that originated from
WAF can hit our origins,
be it an S3 bucket, or an
API gateway, or an ALB.
So when it comes to protecting
the most common use case,
where, where we have a
VPC-based application,
and we need to make sure that only traffic
coming from, from CloudFront
with WAF can hit it,
the best course of action would be
to enable VPC Origins.
It's a kind of a new feature.
We have it for a few
months, so I don't know
how many of you already
use it and know it,
but it's the best way
to protect your origins.
Basically, by enabling VPC Origins,
we turn the load balancer
to become an internal resource.
They no longer have public IP addresses.
They no longer have,
they're no longer accessible
from the internet.
The only thing that can contact these
load balancers is the specific
CloudFront distribution
that we assigned to it.
So it's not even all of CloudFront.
It's a very specific
CloudFront distribution,
and that's called VPC origin.
That, that's the best case scenario.
In case we have an S3 bucket,
the best way to protect that bucket
without making, making it public,
is to enable origin access
control, or OAC, on it.
Basically, that means that whenever
CloudFront communicates to that bucket,
it uses IM policies.
It assumes a role, really, to,
to get access to that bucket.
Just like any other
thing, any other policy
that you would put on a bucket.
The S3 bucket will now have the
CloudFront role assigned and allowed
to fetch the objects
from the bucket, right?
So, these two solutions
will allow you to cloak
and to mask and to protect your resources,
basically forcing traffic to go through
CloudFront and there is no other way in.
In case you don't have one of these
components in the application -
Maybe you're running
an on-prem application,
maybe your application is running
on another cloud, like
Dan will discuss later,
there are still other ways you can utilize
to make sure that no one
can contact your, your,
your origin without
going through CloudFront.
Basically, you would, you would want
to limit access at the IP level
with our managed and
unmanaged prefix lists.
So there's a JSON file
out there on the web,
as well as a managed
prefix list on every VPC
that you can use in your security groups
to make sure that only CloudFront
incoming IP addresses are allowed in.
But that's not good enough because
any CloudFront distribution
can access the application.
And for that reason, we'll
typically want to add,
to add into your CloudFront distribution
configuration, a secret header.
Preferably something that
rotates every once in a while.
And that secret header is being,
being added into every single request
going out of CloudFront
towards the origin.
And it needs to be enforced at the origin,
maybe with an ALB rule,
maybe with an NGINX rule,
but someone needs to look
at the incoming headers
and make sure that only
requests coming with
that secret header are
being allowed through.
So that's, that's just a side discussion
in order to keep a stable and,
and best practice kind of
application architecture.
Let's move on to the what.
So what is a big topic.
How to start building an AWS WAF policy
used to be one of my
biggest conversation topics
with customers, and
I've been dealing with,
with customers about
WAF for too many years
(laughs) that I would like to admit.
But starting kind of recently,
it became super easy.
So one easy way to enable
a WAF policy on top
of your CloudFront is to go into the WAF,
into the CloudFront console and then
I dunno how many of you saw that?
This is kind of new.
We've had it out for about two weeks.
Just pick a flat rate pricing plan
that includes WAF in it.
And it will already include
components of WAF for you.
So if we, if we zoom in for a second,
we will see the different plans
coming all the way from zero for a very
simple configuration still
including CloudFront,
including DNS, including a
simple WAF configuration,
all the way to the
different pricing plans.
And by choosing one of these plans,
you basically get a pre-made policy,
which is typically good enough.
Now these are big words,
"typically good enough".
It's way better than nothing,
and it's a very good start to allow you
to start massaging your
rules into the policy.
It will allow you to start where it's safe
and manageable, and work your way out.
And, and we'll, we'll, we'll talk about
manageability and security,
the security balance, a bit later.
Zooming in into the business offering
in the middle there, just as you see what,
everything that it includes...
I'm just hijacking the discussion
for a second for marketing...
It does include quite a bit.
So it includes the DDoS protection,
it includes storage in S3.
It's, it includes DNS requests.
It's, it's a really nice, nice package
and you can have multiples of these
in your different distributions.
So let's say you have 50 distributions.
Each of them can have one
of these packages attached.
So in, in case you're dealing with
an application that you know nothing about
or you yourself don't
know enough to start out
with a solid WAF configuration,
that would be a very good way
to start from the CloudFront console.
Once you start configuring
or enabling WAF on CloudFront,
there are very simple questions you can,
you can answer by ticking a box.
Do you want SQL, SQL protection?
Do you want rate limiting rules?
Do you want to run in count
mode or monitor mode only?
Very simple toggles. You
don't even have to know WAF.
You or the application
owners that you delegate to,
you don't have to know
really anything about WAF.
It's good enough to start with.
Again, good enough to start with.
You can definitely, and probably, it,
it will be best if you
build on top of this
and add more controls as you go forward.
So this is all the console of AWS,
of, sorry, Amazon CloudFront.
Really easy to begin
building WAF on top of that.
When you start from the WAF console,
the experience is a
bit, is a bit different.
So again, this is a change we've committed
not too many months ago,
so I don't know how many
of you are familiar with it.
Basically, when you create a new web ACL,
or protection pack as we call them now,
you're being asked simple questions
about the application.
What kind of an application is it?
Is it content, content delivery?
Is it an API, is it a mix
of them? Is it retail?
And you just check a box and you start
building your application configuration
from there, without
knowing anything about WAF.
Just basically answering questions
about your application, which you, you,
which you should know.
You or the application owner.
Going from there, you
can pick one of these
pre-made packages,
pre-made protection packs
that include a good
enough security policy.
It contains a bit more than the CloudFront
deployed policy does, assuming that if
you are already on the WAF console,
you probably know a bit more
and you'll be allowed into
more of the secret sauce.
So again, three options.
A basic one, basically rate limiting,
IP reputation services enabled,
bot controlled in count
mode, common bot control.
You can move on to the essential pack
and you can have more.
So more is not necessarily
always better, right?
We obviously want to strive
to a very robust, feature rich policy
that protects you against
different kind of things
that happen in the internet, but it,
it may incur some costs
on you, operational costs.
And typically when we
start too strong with WAF,
and I've seen it happen multiple times,
not with AWS WAF,
necessarily, but all WAFs.
When you start, when
you come on too strong
with WAF at the first sign of trouble,
like, you're getting false positives,
you're getting blocked requests,
there's too much to handle
and you just switch it off.
And the, the hurdle you have to
jump through in order to re-enabling it
after getting bird is super high.
So I would suggest starting low and
building on top of that,
on what you already have,
and you already have
established trust with.
You know how the mechanism works,
you know where the logs are,
you know how to tune things.
You can start building from that.
Once you configure the
application policy through WAF,
there are a few other
things you can configure,
such as what are the
rate limit thresholds?
So, it could be anything
that fits your application.
I think we start here
with a thousand requests
per IP per minute, or per,
per five minutes, sorry.
But you can tune that into something
as low as 10 requests, if that's what
your application needs, or as high as
two billion requests, if that's what
your application needs.
So we start out with a good normal number,
but you can tune that.
And this part here is super simple,
but super important to enable,
and that's logging.
So you just have to say,
"I want logging," basically ticking a box.
And the same goes by, by the way,
on the CloudFront console.
Super easy to enable WAF logging
and it sends logging
towards CloudWatch logs.
Now, going back to the fixed pricing plan
that we announced a few weeks ago,
logs are included in that pricing plan.
So it's no longer a concern.
CloudWatch logs, which are the easiest way
to manage WAF logs, are
included in the pricing plan.
So you can just go ahead,
check the box and enable that.
Even without that,
without the pricing plan,
on the good old pay as you go model,
we've decreased the price
of CloudWatch logs with WAF.
We now provide 500 megabytes
of free logs per every million WAF
requests that you send through.
So it really reduces, help reduce
the cost in case you don't go with the
protection plan, or with
the pricing plan, sorry.
So summarizing, we know
what, we know the what.
We know we're going
for the essential pack.
We know what we're getting.
We're getting some IP based blocks,
we're getting geolocation based blocks,
we're getting some very good core HTTP
compliance protection rules.
We're getting what we
call "known bad inputs"
or "known vulnerabilities"
like Log four J,
all with a simple click.
We're even getting the new layer seven
DDoS rule in count mode.
So it's already enabled,
it's in the right place in
the policy at the very top.
And all the remains to
us is just monitoring
what it does and enable
it when we're ready.
Time for a well earned coffee.
So I got there in the
morning, I got the news
of the new application.
I built with a few clicks, the,
the WAF policy that fits my needs.
Now it's time to look at the logs.
This, this is what makes me feel good:
looking at dashboards all day.
I really like that, so.
I don't know how similar
you think this guy is to me.
I tried. I'm even wearing the,
I'm even wearing the same kind of shirt.
Imagine that, that is me.
That's the best I could do with AI.
I'm a WAF guy, not an AI guy.
So out of the box with AWS WAF,
you have these built-in dashboards.
Again, it used to be a pain to,
to spin up dashboards in WAF.
Or I would say a relative pain,
where you had to know what you're doing
and what kind of queries you need to run
to build a CloudWatch dashboard widget.
Now starting June, last June, we launched
this new UI with this, these super useful
dashboard widgets that really allow you
to see where traffic is coming from,
which rules are being hit,
what kind of bot traffic you're seeing,
what kind of DDoS traffic you're seeing.
Really, really dive into
the different insights,
top IP addresses, top
URIs, top user agents,
top fingerprints, JA3, JA4 fingerprints.
All useful stuff enabled by default.
And the most important
thing, you can start
navigating the logs
directly from the console.
So no need to run these
tiring CloudWatch log queries.
It's all built in.
You can click an IP
address on the top IP list
and filter by that IP and start seeing
what these IPs are doing
in your application.
Each of these lines is
basically clickable.
You can see the full request details,
the IP address, the reputation,
the query string parameters, the labels
that we accumulated for
that specific request.
And everything is actionable.
So you can take anything out of it,
put it back in the filter.
Show me more requests with this URL.
Show me more, more requests
with this fingerprint.
And you can still use the good old
CloudWatch log insight queries if you need
to build something more comprehensive,
like more advanced querying.
Obviously, this is all true if you're
using CloudWatch logs,
but it does make sense
because it's cheaper, it's
included in the pricing plan.
But if you're using other destination
for logging, we'll talk about that.
You can use the same kind of schemes
to build your own dashboards.
Run Athena queries on top of S3 and so on.
Like, like we, like you used to.
We didn't change, we didn't change that.
Okay, looking at the logs, I feel relaxed.
I had my coffee, it's
time for the lunch break.
And you know what, let's put
the "break" in lunch break.
So just sitting down to have my lunch,
we're starting, I start to hear yells
from upstairs in marketing.
They say something about
403 customers complaining.
Probably something they misheard.
So I, I start looking at the dashboard
and I see these 403s.
I see multiple blocks coming from
different IP addresses, all with the
CrossSiteScripting in body rule being hit.
So I, I, I have a sneaking suspicion
it's gonna be a false positive
that I have to mitigate.
So I start diving into
the, into the logs more.
I see different IP addresses.
I, I look at these IP addresses
and I see that they're basically benign.
They're doing good things.
They're logging in,
they're purchasing bots,
they're posting on the forum,
but they're also triggering this
one rule on a very specific webpage
where we are detecting
a CrossSiteScripting
attempt in the body.
I'm assuming this is a false positive.
We have to deal with it.
So first rule in dealing with false
positives is stay calm.
Don't turn off WAF, don't
roll back the change.
Try and understand exactly
what is the pattern
that triggers the false positive.
Once you do that, it could
be a, a, a specific URI,
it could be a specific parameter,
it could be anything
really in the request,
but by looking and navigating through
the dashboard, you really can pinpoint and
you start building a rule around that.
So you see now I'm calm.
Again, I think this guy looks like me.
So first we go and switch off the rule
that triggered the false positive.
In our case, it was a CrossSiteScripting
attempt in the request body.
So we go and turn that
off, or switch it to count.
Right? So now no more
users are getting blocked,
but then again, we're not enforcing
CrossSiteScripting in body anymore,
which is not a good thing.
So we are building a different rule
right after the rule
that that triggered the,
the, the false positive.
And that rule is built in a way that says
still block CrossSiteScripting attacks
based on this label, and we'll talk about
the label in a second.
Still mitigate CrossSiteScripting attacks,
but don't do it if the URI is
slash missing robots form.
Because that was the one
that I saw in my logs.
So by that, I basically
turned CrossSiteScripting
in body back on, back into
being, being enforced.
But I exempted the, this
specific URI from that rule.
All other attacks on
that URI are still valid.
So this is a very good, fine-grain way
to mitigate false positives.
So once we do that, we start tuning.
So tuning helps us avoid chaos.
So tune your policy often, tune it early,
don't wait for something to happen.
So review the logs, make sure that
you're doing the right things.
Enough traffic is being
blocked, enough blocked.
Enough traffic is being let through.
When you do make changes,
make changes gradually.
Don't add five different
rules on the same day.
So again, too much is not
better necessarily with WAF.
So add rules gradually, monitor effect.
And manage your traffic with labels.
So there's a little
star there, with labels.
I don't know how many of you know labels,
but labels are my and your best friend
when it comes to WAF,
so a bit about labels.
Labels are metadata that we add into
every single request
that goes through WAF.
We can add them with managed rules -
By default, all managed
rules add different labels.
For example, these are
the labels being emitted
by the core rule set, a part of them.
There are more.
We can add labels on our custom rules
as part of the action.
We can use them as a match or
scope down condition on rules.
So, let's say I want to not inspect
certain traffic from a certain IP address.
I can create a custom
rule that adds a label
to all traffic from a certain,
from a certain IP address and then
use that label to scope down another rule
to not inspect that specific traffic.
So we use labels. It will help you
investigate because labels
are visible in your logs.
They are visible in CloudWatch metrics
and they're also usable if you want
to filter out certain rules
or certain traffic patterns from your logs
because they're too, too noisy
or cost too much or whatever.
So labels, super useful tool.
They're like the multi-tool of WAF.
They can really be used to do anything.
So add them, add them always.
Then think about what to do with them.
Labels are your best friends.
Then lastly... I know I'm
running late, don't worry.
Lastly, after ...
Typically ... I'm from Israel.
So typically at 2:00 PM,
we're having a coffee.
I don't know how it is in the US,
but at 2:00 PM we're breaking for coffee.
Typically, it's a strong black coffee.
So that time I would use
to optimize my costs.
So I tuned my policy.
I know that I'm blocking
the, the bad stuff.
I know that I'm letting
through the good stuff.
It's already deployed, but now
I'm making sure that I'm not making any,
any mistakes when it comes to costs.
So in order to control our cost,
we initially make, need to make sure
that the right things
are getting blocked at
the right places with WAF.
So making sure that the layer seven
DDoS rule at the, is, is at the very top
because whenever it blocks traffic,
it is not incurring any costs.
So, blocked requests are
free in layer seven DDoS
even without a pricing plan.
So making sure that this
rule is going first.
Making sure that other paid rules,
such as bot control,
are scoped down and only
getting traffic which we
think they should inspect.
And also looking at logs where
I need to make sure that logs are not
being carried over for too long.
So, setting up a specific
log retention period,
whatever your business
needs, be it 14 days
or seven years, but make sure that
you stick to that and
don't carry logs forever.
Use labels again to filter out noisy logs.
And again, switch to flat rate plans.
Really predictable. No overages.
You know what you're getting every month
When it comes to logs, I really rush,
I will really rush through with it
because CloudWatch logs are
the easiest to configure.
Typically the cheapest, especially if
you have low rates of traffic.
When it comes to higher
rates, you might want
to consider other ways
to send out WAF logs.
You might want to consider Kinesis,
Data Fare, Fire Hose, which is,
outside of the pricing plan, probably the
cheapest way for very
high volumes of traffic.
It can also be used to send traffic
to different locations like S3,
like an, an external, a third party ...
vendor like a SaaS offering.
And lastly, you can
use S3 buckets directly
to send out WAF logs
directly to an S3 bucket.
Behind the scenes it
does use CloudWatch logs.
So at high volumes you might incur some,
some vending costs that you don't expect,
but it's the easiest to configure.
So preferably CloudWatch logs.
If not that, Kinesis Fire Hose.
If you need S3, use the Kinesis Fire Hose
to send traffic or logs towards S3.
And finally, if you're
using pricing plans,
it's really easy to see if you're about to
breach the contract that you've signed.
You can see, based on what you
already had in the month, like, how soon
will you breach the,
the quota that you got?
Like, out of the 500 million requests,
how many you already sent?
Same goes for data transfer,
but it's fine though.
If you're about to breach, as long as it's
not a consistent breach, like every month
you, you're breaching,
there will be no overages.
If this is happening more often than not,
that you're breaching your quotas,
eventually you will
experience some throttling.
But for that we have a very clear
dashboard in the UI allowing you to
keep track of where you're going
and is that plan the right plan for you?
So this is the end of my coffee break
and I'll hand it over to Dan.
- [Dan Avidan] Thank you. Hello everyone.
Hopefully having a great Reinvent so far.
I'm Dan Avidan from HSBC Retail Bank,
IWPB, International Wealth
and Premier Banking.
And I'm gonna walk you
through our WAF journey.
So first, in terms of who we are and
where we sit within the organization,
we are digital enablers.
So we provide things like common
frameworks and platforms pertaining to
mobile authentication and authorization,
business process orchestration.
And of course what we are
gonna talk about today,
which is our edge routing
and protection platform.
The services that we provide specifically
allow the various value stream
to concentrate on their specific business
verticals without having to worry about
things such as WAF protection.
So HSBC, one of the
biggest banks in the world.
We operate in a large number of markets.
Some of them, and the
vast majority of them,
for example, can adapt AWS.
But there's other ones, for
example, where we cannot.
So we need to make sure that we operate
across multiple cloud providers.
So for example, highly regulated markets
that have debt residency
requirements like China
where we cannot use AWS.
Or markets like Egypt, for example,
where we cannot use any
cloud providers yet.
We have to make sure
that we port WAF rules
and our WAF protection
across the entire state.
We operate in a highly
regulated environment.
Every downtime have to be
reported to regulators.
So protecting the brand,
protecting against DDoS attacks is
really of the outmost importance.
Maybe perhaps a few interesting anecdotes.
There's markets, for example, when we own
white label brands such as Marks & Spencer
Money in the UK.
In Asia Pacific, for example, we own
competing brand that we
need to keep separation
between them to meet
anti-competition laws.
For example, Hang Seng Bank
versus Hong Kong Retail Bank.
We own not only banking, but
insurance product as well.
So all in all, ultimately it creates
a fairly diverse traffic
pattern to our sites,
which we obviously need
to take account for
in our various WAF rules.
We have a regulatory obligation to allow
our customers to transact.
If people can't access their money,
it obviously erodes trust
in the financial industry,
which regulators feel very strongly about.
And of course, peak times tends to be in
challenging times during
geopolitical tensions,
during natural disasters,
which makes it challenging as well.
In terms of our team specifically,
so as mentioned, we operate
in a large number of markets.
We have multiple non production
and production AWS account.
We support many value streams.
Each one of those value streams
have multiple applications.
So if you do the math, it ultimately
ends up being a huge, huge attack surface,
which means that our WAF protections
really have to be top-notch.
We get hundreds of terabytes
worth of traffic each month.
Billions upon billions of requests.
We have hundreds of
CloudFront distributions,
multiple web ACLs, and again,
supporting multiple cloud providers.
And unfortunately the reality is
that we're literally under daily attacks.
It's not something that
happens once in a blue moon.
It's literally around the clock,
there's some sort of an attack going on.
I'm not gonna dwell on this slide too much
'cause it's not, those challenge,
banking challenges are not WAF specific,
but it is interesting to know that we're
seeing regulators more and
more interested in WAF.
Not so much in the US, but more certainly
in Europe from the European Central Bank.
And in Asia Pacific, WAF is now
a mandatory regulatory requirement.
So it's quite interesting to see
regulators getting involved and
mandating the use of WAF.
In terms of when the journey started,
well, interesting enough also in
Reinvent back in 2018, which coincided
with the need to create
a new cloud platform.
I was personally really inspired with
all things serverless, so it was a
personal crusade to try and do it
completely serverlessly, which we did.
Of course, the migration to cloud have
taken longer than we anticipated.
We're still operating in a
hybrid cloud environment,
which requires special WAF considerations.
The intention was to specifically
shift security left to try and obstruct
third party service
providers in our origins
from sensitive security
tokens, making sure
that we really make sure
that they don't have
to worry about the edge protection.
And this is something
that we're providing,
and again, we're doing it all through
compute at the edge,
completely serverlessly.
So it is the architecture,
nothing too exotic, right?
So SHIELD provides the
layer four mitigation,
which passes request to CloudFront
and of course WAF inspect the, the,
the request, which if not blocked,
passes it over to Lambda.
So you can see there's
no EC2 reverse boxing.
It's all done serverlessly.
This predates CloudFront function.
Ideally now, some of this we would
migrate to CloudFront function.
And the other thing to take away,
that we are not protecting
just AWS origin.
We created a generic, abstracted platform
that provide protection to a wide
variety of origins, specifically On Prem
and even, even other cloud providers.
So for example, some GCP based origins.
Okay, some challenges.
So one, it's an ever
evolving threat landscape.
Back when we started, DDoS
was really not so much
of a problem and if it
did, then AWS shield
would mitigate the layer four type attacks
and you get to claim credit without
really having to do much for it, right?
AWS shield would kick in, mitigate the
attack and, and you're done.
To layer seven attacks, right?
Malicious attempts to your domain name
slash ETC password, right?
Hoping to get lucky.
To high volume attacks, which we in the
industry responded with rate-based tools.
To then of course, to
low and slow type attack.
And of course, the concern
these days is agentic.
So for example, if I have a genuine agent
that I really, really want to transfer
money on my behalf, how do I distinguish
my legitimate agent
from a malicious agent?
The reality is that unfortunately
execs don't really understand WAF.
The type, even if you're
not a tier one bank,
the type of thing that your management
have probably told you is things like,
"Well make sure that, can you confirm that
you're getting paged every
time we're under attack?"
No, the team's never gonna get any sleep.
We're constantly under attack.
You want to get paged, for example,
when the origin are suffering.
When, when the origins are under duress.
There's gonna be a
misconception, for example,
that you invest in WAF
once and it's done, right?
So whatever money I invested this year,
I don't have to spend it again next year.
No, the reality is that you have to
continuously invent,
you continuously have to
make sure that you enhance WAF
to protect against new threats.
Specifically given the serverless nature
of our platform, when there there,
there were attacks that did breach
our perimeters ... We got hit for example,
for doing it serverlessly, right?
Saying, "Well if you were to use EC2,
you wouldn't have those issues.
Why are you using Lambda?"
And the key to take away is that no amount
of compute in the world is gonna mitigate
a really high volume DDoS attack, right?
It's not about the compute that you use.
The key is to have really strong
WAF protection in place
to thwart the attacks.
It's not about the compute
type that you're using.
The other reality is that engineers or
application teams don't
really understand WAF, right?
It's not something that, unfortunately,
they deal with on a daily basis, right?
They probably understand
API gateway really well.
Kubernetes, EC2. WAF, not really.
Plus they're obviously under pressure
to provide new business capabilities.
WAF is probably not one of them.
Cyber on the other hand, understand
security really well, but don't really
understand the applications
and how to protect them.
And this is where our team comes in,
to kind of try and bridge this gap
between cyber and application team.
We are in between trying
to bridge that gap.
From an application perspective,
if you're using AWS firewall manager,
organizational policies like you should
say, "Oh, I have 10 type rules."
Then you have to think, how do I
integrate applications specific,
or AWS account specific rules
into those policies?
Do I do it at build time?
Do I do it at run time?
There's some consideration there.
AWS WAF, unfortunately, let's say like
AWS gateway doesn't
have deployment stages.
So you really have to think about,
how am I gonna roll out my new rules?
Maybe I've done a really good job
consolidating into a single cloud fund
distribution onto a single WAF web ACL.
But if now you have one WAF rule that
does something that it shouldn't,
all of a sudden the
entire organization down.
So you have to think,
am I gonna do it through
blue green web ACLs that
I'm toggling between?
Or maybe I just create artificially more
web ACLs than I need to just minimize
the blast radius for my organization.
It's counterintuitive, but detecting
actual attacks can
actually be complicated.
Maybe the business had a really, really
successful campaign that they didn't
notify you about and you're getting
a lot of requests that
seems really distributed.
Well, is it a genuine user's
traffic or is it an attack?
So you have to think,
am I really gonna know
when I'm being attacked,
or is it genuine traffic?
If you're using the AWS managed
WAF rules like you should,
you have to think how do I tune them?
For example, if you have an AWS WAF
or stop 10 rule to
restrict a certain size,
then what happens if all of a sudden
one of your application
needs to be able to
support a threshold higher than that?
Say, for document uploads, for example.
So you really want to be able to tune
for that specific journey,
for that specific application,
to minimize the impact.
And this tuning can take time.
So here is a specific example
for tuning an Amazon managed rule.
It took us quite a bit of time,
including support from AWS.
I'm not gonna go through it line by line,
but you can see the the type of changes
that we needed to make, ranging from
application changes to the way in which
we're acquiring the AWS WAF tokens.
Some changes even on the AWS
side by the service team.
Shout out to the service team. Thank you.
Quite amazing agility where AWS have
rolled out some enhancement across
the entire state within a sprint.
So yeah, and agility that
we can definitely aspire to.
Eventually it was time well spent because
we were able to achieve the business
accepted level of false positive.
So don't be, don't be scared away from it.
It was ultimately, it allowed us
to create a cookie cutter report
across this two initial tuning
periods in those two markets.
We were able to then roll it out
successfully to the other 35 markets.
Some challenges on the WAF side.
So you really have to think
like Tzoori mentioned,
how do you protect your on premise origin?
Previously with VPC
origin for the AWS origin,
there used to be this restriction
that now is no longer there.
So we're excited to now roll it out wider.
VPC Origins don't, no longer need
to be within the same AWS
account as CloudFront.
If you're adding CloudFront distribution
from a regular basis, you need to remember
that they don't automatically enroll
in the shield advanced auto mitigation.
So if you're adding
CloudFront distribution,
you need to make sure that you are
enrolling them so that they're protected.
And actually, only recently realized that
while WAF can add custom labels,
while there's no triggers
for CloudFront function
for Lambda@Edge, WAF could in fact
inject headers as well, which then
you can do quite interesting things with,
within CloudFront
functions or Lambda@Edge.
So, quite useful.
We learned the hard way that at the time,
our logging solution was not scaling to
DDoS attack, so something that
you want to be thinking about.
I'm sure you have a
working logging solution,
but you want to make sure that
it can scale up during DDoS attack.
It's quite important, or else how are
you gonna analyze data can be able to add,
for example, JA4 based
rules to mitigate it?
Yes, CloudWatch logs insight is there,
but for our traffic we noticed that
you can have quite a bit
long running queries.
It's not the cheapest service.
So we, for example, exploring using
AWS OpenSearch instead.
Some final lesson
learned, and I appreciate
it's like saying sell
stocks high, buy them low.
But what I mean by protect against
tomorrow's attack, not yesterday,
have you added any new infrastructure?
Have you added any new applications?
Do application have new capabilities that
you really want to add
new WAF rules for them?
WAF does come with API,
if you're not aware,
the WAF automation framework.
So you can mine the logs for
interesting events, right?
If there's any IPs, for
example, that introducing
any 404, any extra or
large number of 500 errors,
why not automatically block them,
say, for 24 hours period?
Know who your TAMS and
solution architects are.
We derive tremendous value from them.
They can enroll you in IWS betas and,
and various previews.
Continue to invest in your
stock and your WAF team.
It's not something that, you're not
setting WAF and forget it.
It requires continuous investment.
And of course the AWS
SRT team is always there,
but you really want to be able
to independently analyze your log,
mine your logs, and be
able to add, for example,
JA4 fingerprint blocking rules yourself.
And yeah, automation is absolutely key.
You don't want to be
there at 2:00 AM in the
morning, figuring out how
to revert back a rule.
So automation is absolutely key.
In terms of what's coming up,
coming up for us next is to
ultimately capitalize on the
investment that we've made in WAF so far.
Making sure that we roll everything that
we have done and by consolidating our
various endpoints and
thousands upon thousands
of domains onto our top level domains so
that they can ultimately benefit from this
very protection that we spoke about.
Back to you, Tzoori.
- [Tzoori Tamam] Thanks, Dan.
And I, I know HSBC is a big bank.
A lot of the challenges they encountered
are not your challenges,
but learning from them
and seeing that it's
possible even at their scale,
to basically use WAF as a layer
to protect all of the
applications they have -
thousands and thousands of them -
is a really good practice.
Now, as the day grow, goes, grows long,
I tend to be more philosophical
and I want to look into the future
and see what else is possible.
As Dan said, we have to look ahead
when it comes to AWS WAF.
We can't be reactive.
We have to be proactive and be faster,
or at least as fast as the attackers
that look to harm us.
So practicing new rules, adding new rules,
configuring, tuning,
tightening the security.
I, I will talk about
three different things,
rushing through for the last few minutes.
Initially what's, we'll
talk about bot control,
we'll talk about layer seven protection,
and we'll talk about the
general use for new rules,
new, new custom rules
and new managed rules.
So when it comes to bot control, again,
my company completely
misunderstood what bot,
what bots really mean.
But for bot control, you
can use the managed rule
that we have to first identify
common bots for good and bad.
So specifically allowing in search engines
or SEO engines, that's an important thing.
That can be achieved with
the common bot control.
Or maybe blocking noisy health checkers
that come from the web, just because
they are self-identifying,
That's an easy thing you can do
with common bot control.
Detecting and, and finding the more
sophisticated bots, what
we call targeted bots.
The bots that were built in order
to specifically harm your application.
This is where we typically enable targeted
bot control, the next
level of bot control,
where we can track abnormal behaviors.
Not only a specific request, but looking
throughout the session lifetime and see
which sessions are more volumetric
or they differ, they differ dramatically
from normal user sessions.
So we can start challenging
them with a Captcha,
with a JavaScript challenge,
or just plainly blocking them if we see
that they're acting too suspiciously.
And now with the age of AI and AI bots,
a lot of your incoming traffic...
And when I say a lot,
sometimes more than 50%
of your incoming traffic might
be generated by AI agents.
Some of them benign,
some of them not so much.
All of them very noisy, and you have to
make sure that you're only
allowing the good ones in.
So by utilizing bot control, make sure
that you upgrade to the latest
version of bot control, version four.
You can now use Web Auth-, Web Bot Auth,
it's a mouthful, to make sure that
only the allow agents, the allowed,
the verified agents are allowed into
your application and all other agents
probably should somehow register
and verify with this.
It's not, not yet a standard,
but this is the mechanism
most WAF providers
and agent registries used to make sure
that only good bots are
being allowed through.
Where it comes to layer seven DDoS,
again, this is kind of a new rule,
so if you don't, if you're not aware
or are not familiar with
it, be familiar with it.
There will be a QR card,
a QR code at the end.
You can scan and learn more about it.
But by enabling the
essentials pack, we got this,
we got this included in
the business pricing plan
and we can start using it.
It was created with the
override check enabled.
So once we saw in the dashboard...
There's a specific dashboard for DDoS.
Once we saw it causes
no false positives...
And it doesn't, it's a
very safe rule to use.
You can just check off this box
and see that it only
acts during DDoS attacks.
It's super silent, it's doing nothing
during peace times, but only when
there is an actual event, it starts
targeting the offensive actors,
be it specific IP addresses, or countries,
or AS numbers, or user agents,
or, or fingerprints.
And only those will get this challenge or
eventually get blocked if
they, if they don't behave.
So make sure that you use that
super important, very powerful tool.
Where, when it comes to evolving your WAF,
so adding new rules, so make sure
that you track your traffic.
Traffic changes, right?
You can maybe go viral, see more traffic.
You might go viral in a bad way,
where attackers look out to harm you.
So make sure that you keep track of all of
the traffic, not only
the one that you block.
Only, also the ones that you are,
you are being allowed in,
that is being allowed in.
Are different rules being hit?
Are different rules not being,
being hit all of a sudden?
Maybe we're missing something.
Maybe some attacker evolved and now
we're not finding them anymore.
So make sure that you
track traffic all the time.
On the flip side though, strike the
right balance between a secure policy
and a manageable policy, right?
The most secure computer
is locked in a safe,
disconnected from the
world. That's not usable.
So strike the right balance for you.
I don't know how much time you have to
invest in WAF, but it is
an investment in time.
So add the rules that you
get the most value out of.
Even if it's not the perfect
WAF policy, that's good enough.
The best WAF policy is the
one that you can manage,
Otherwise, you'll just turn it off and
do nothing with it, which is way worse.
So strike the right balance, tighten the
right rules, make sure that the, the,
the rate based rule that you encountered
or introduce into the
policy, not only track
IP addresses, but also track
fingerprints, methods, labels.
Again, make, make full use
of what WAF has to offer.
And this is an ongoing effort.
You make WAF tighter
and tighter and tighter
as the attacker become more
and more and more sophisticated.
Another good practice is to maintain
a staging environment.
Dan mentioned it a bit.
Keep track of your changes,
roll them out gradually.
Make sure that you are, you,
you expect what they will be doing
if you're launching them into production.
Build your label logic in a way
that allows you to test it out
in your staging environments, right?
If you have the luxury of it, great.
In some scenarios you can
even add the same rules
to the same... Oh, sorry.
Add new rules to the same
policy, in count mode.
Even managed rules, you
can add multiples of them
and make sure and seeing
your production traffic,
how they would've behaved were they in
blocking mode and not in count mode.
So if you don't have the capacity to
run a full staging
environment, at least do that.
Add multiple versions of the same rule
into the policy with
different actions on them,
order them correctly and
see what would happen
if you switch a, a rule into block.
Again, labels are your friends.
And lastly, remember AWS WAF
configurations are code, right?
If you look at the WAF console,
there is this JSON button up there.
The entire WAF configuration
is just a JSON document, right?
So use it, use this power, use the API
that a WAF provides to automate.
Use infrastructure as code tooling.
It allows for better versionings,
better, better change management.
It allows for automation when
it comes to new deployments.
So if you have the resource to do it...
and with AI writing most of your
automations now, it's super simple
and it will save you
a lot of pain day 100.
Day one, everything is quick and dirty.
Day 100, probably we
should be doing better.
So the day is done, the
application is good for now.
Tomorrow's a new day, obviously.
And on the drive home, I'm reflecting
on the lessons learned
from this busy, busy day.
So we talked about architecture
and cloaking your origins.
We talked about a good
enough initial policy.
Build it however you want:
manually, with the pricing plan packages,
with the WAF configuration
protection packs, whatever.
But do something day one, right?
Even a policy with a
single rule in count mode
and logging is way better than no policy.
At least you get visibility.
Do the one thing you know you can
manage and then grow from there.
But make sure you do follow up,
and do follow up quickly and repeatedly.
The web is a bad place, right?
So I'm not here to scare you, I'm just
here to show that WAF
is an ongoing effort.
And I've been doing WAF
for too many years now.
Utilizing new pricing plans.
Super prediction, predictable, super easy.
They contain a bunch of value in them
for a, for a fixed price.
Make sure that your WAF configurations
are evolving as attackers will evolve.
So make sure that you introduce new rules,
upgrade your rule versions if,
if there are managed rules.
Keep on testing, keep on viewing the logs,
keep on looking for what changed
in traffic, in rule hits.
What rules are, what,
what rules are being hit,
what rules are being
missed, right? As important.
And automate and test your
changes if you can, right?
So it's a, it's a repeated,
it's a repeatable,
predictable, easily rolled back process.
WAF configurations are
code, treat them like code.
Now I promised three QR codes.
Don't scan them, take a picture of it.
One will be a blog about the
new flat rate pricing plans.
It's new, so we'll learn about them.
We didn't cover a lot in depth about them,
but they're super useful.
And these two other QR codes deal with
layer seven DDoS mitigation
with our new managed rule.
So the one blog is a launch blog,
the middle one, and the right hand side...
Your, yeah, right hand side, is more
of a deep dive into how to configure it
and how to tune it if you need to.
And with that, I really
appreciate your time.
I know it's a, you know,
busy hour, long day.
Some of you're still jet lagged or worse.
So thank you for your time.
We would really appreciate the feedback
if you can leave it in the app.
And have a great rest of the week.
Thank you all.
(applause)